this is going to be a talk on outlier
detection in time series signal I'm
going to
Achilles he works as a machine learning
/ NLP engineer at CB insights where he
applies machine learning algorithms to
NLP problems he received his BS from be
kent university and ms from the new york
university focusing on signal processing
and machine learning so let's welcome it
thank you for everyone so today I be
talking about outlier detection in time
series signals this is from XKCD as you
may guess so we have data but data is
problems we have using observations nice
outliers today I'm going to talk about
mainly for outliers but I'll also
introduce a 50 based approach to remove
the noise from the time series signals
as well so our place where there is
because there are logistical problems I
didn't transmission or transcription
there are experimental errors and its
procedures measurement errors component
failures and so on but to begin with
what is it right what is an outlier
there are people who define outliers in
various ways but I'll stick with the
with this definition not because it is
it captures the best in terms of what an
outlier is but I guess it captures the
common sense common sense of the people
when they think about outlier today I
will talk about three different methods
one of them is medium filtering approach
one of them is a 50 base and the other
one is Monte Carlo Markov chain model so
to begin with medium filter yesterday
rayon talk about how many ways is a
punching bag of the classifiers I guess
today the medium filter is a punching
bag of the methods it is quite simple we
are just sliding a window size W and
then replace the original value with the
data point as you may guess the median
is not
near doesn't submit the signal unlike an
averaging window and it is robust
outliers so this is this is a toy
example we have a original signal X and
we slide over window size w3 and then
replace the value with the medium value
for in order to handle the percent last
videos we extend left mouse and right
mouse will use and complete boundaries
so the original signal is left the
signal without lights is right what we
want to try to do is to be able to
capture or at least detect the outliers
and remove it from signal so this is
quite simple approach we first get the
difference as abstract a meeting of the
signal this difference is called Midian
absolute deviation and then we get the
median of that meeting absolute
deviation and then look at the median
difference if it is smaller than some
threshold this threshold is arbitrary
and it depends on how much you want to
capture or how much you want to preserve
the variance of the signal and then we
put a mask based on the threshold and
then return the signal so this is the
and the first one is the medium filter
signals the second one is the original
signal the you could just ignore the
boundaries because I didn't handle for
this specific case but it introduces
also some problems around here and here
because the signal verizon odd but
overall if you compare with the original
signal I think it is quite successful at
least we really reduce the very soft
outliers quite a lot so the baby
elephants don't know how to use their
trunks to drink water
get miserable whenever they want to
drink water we know a powerful tools FFT
to deal with time varies and signal a 50
is useful for it but no noise removal
and also outlier detection noise in the
sense notice so differs from outliers in
the sense that it doesn't necessarily
distance from the main signal it may
travel on top of the signal and also not
necessarily random it may be modeled is
a Gaussian see Gaussian noise or some
background process may generate those
noise and also may have dependents to
the original signal the first 10 so the
fft is actually a misnomer when a 50
when people have to say fft they
actually mean discrete Fourier transform
fft is just a particular implementation
of how to compute DFT it is from cooley
and turkey from 60s but the algorithm is
itself is so successful and nobody not
actually talks about the FD even if when
they say affected they actually mean DFT
the first equation is how to go from
time series signal to frequency domain
and the second one is the how to go from
for frequency domain and time domain the
term e to the minus J 2 pi K over N may
seem a little bit dangerous but I will I
will simplify that in a bit so this is
actually the original algorithm fft
block is this simplifies the computation
of fft computation of DFT from all n
square to n or n log n it is a recursive
method if you want to take 18 point fft
you could kind of divided into two eight
point fft and then you could recursively
also divide 8.8 50s into 24.8 50s and so
on
and the Euler's formula is handy in
order to compete or at this to reason
about how to compute FFT the term e to
the minus J 2 pi K overrun gets
simplified by using Euler's formula with
a bunch of cosine and sinusoid of X and
so what is for you so we have a signal
like some odd signals it varies but not
too much we when we complete the DFT we
get some frequency component which
actually corresponds to the practice of
the cosine in this case cosine 1x
correspond to 1 cosine 3x correspond to
3 and so on what's good about a 50s when
you have an arbitrary signal which
really doesn't look like a sinusoid or
cosine you could kind of fit different
frequency of cosine and science to get
or at least to approximate the signal
with different coefficients of the
cosine and sinusoids so this is Sir oh
come on
oh so in here we are trying to
approximate the square wave with a bunch
of sinusoids and after we accumulate
kind of a lot of sinusoids we could be
quite successful and sorry about this
anyway so when we want to remove noise
removal the left one is the original
signal and the right one is the signal
with noise this noise is just a Gaussian
noise on top of original signal and it
has also some DC component so it is not
just high frequency signal but also low
frequency the original signal is five
Hertz and we want to be able to remove
the noise from the signal totally so
when we take the DFT of the signal the
frequency response looks like this the
y-axis is log scale so the difference
between those two guys and the rest of
is actually quite run different the
these two guys is actually five Hertz
which is the original signal and the
remaining frequency compounds are just
noise as you might guess yes so in
frequency domain we could just detect
those frequencies and then remove the
remaining frequency components and to
get the original signal so the first one
is the original signal the second one is
they're noisy and when we apply the FFT
this is also called bandwidth filtering
band pass filtering then we get a
original signal which is a frequency
component at five Hertz so how do we use
this one to remove outliers noise is
easy because we know exactly what we are
targeting for at least in frequency
sense so we could just slide the window
like we do in the median filtering case
and then get the frequency response of
the signal in that window and then look
at some arbitrary f marks this F marks
corresponds to also the various or the
jump that we want to capture or want to
preserve in the signal and then if that
signal is if that Windows signals
frequency component is larger than F max
then for each observation we just look
at it and then remove it and then take
care 50 and then unless the signal the
signals frequency is smaller than F
marks we just remove those this is the
Python implementation of the algorithm
in here we have also the frequency
amplitude in order to capture how much
the original component that we want to
get but the implementations are
relatively straightforward and the
second part is just sliding window case
we are just looking at a window and then
get out light positions and then return
them so ended up in the first outlier
signals this is quite successful and
unlike median filtering we didn't
disturb the signal any case but which we
are able to capture all of the outliers
so the third method that I'll be and
spending some time outlier detection
where montecarlo Markov chain so today
josh oblem talk a little bit about how
they are using mcmc to estimate some of
the distances of the planets this could
be somehow related we are also trying to
estimate parameters in in the signals so
Monte Carlo Markov chain is actually a
combination of Monte Carlo something and
markov chain monte carlo itself is
useful for
estimate parameters of a distribution
and this could be any characteristic of
it any characteristics of a distribution
markov chain is a stochastic process to
get or to sample different states from a
stationary distribution mcmc kind of
combined spot of the goodness of what
monte carlo and markov chain we design a
markov chain in such a way that we
actually get the target distributions
characteristics by sampling this
sampling to different states so an easy
metro police testing sampler in order to
get the posterior distribution is could
be designed in this way so we have a
time indexed signal X 1 X 2 X T we just
initialize X 1 to a random number a we
have a proposal distribution to sample
the candidate value and assuming the
transition matrix is symmetric this is
our decision criterion in the if we want
to get that observation or not this is
basically about it so how do we
implement in python is like this so we
start with number of iterations also we
put some burning since we are
initializing to some random number the
first samplings wouldn't be very useful
in order to estimate characteristics of
the distribution so so we just don't
want to include in our in our resulting
posterior distribution and we just these
posterior distributions and proposal
distributions are arbitrary whatever you
want to capture in your model you could
sign in that way and then we the
acceptance criterion as I shot it just
looks for the minimum value of the with
one and the possible candidates proposal
distribution will you and then and then
we flip a coin and then if the
acceptance criterion is about that we
include the observation otherwise we
don't and we do this iteration and until
the number of iterations gets so but the
problem is this implementation is very
simple generally doesn't really work
well because it doesn't have convergence
properties it doesn't provide anything
very useful out of 10 the sampler itself
generally pie MC is the as Josh oblem
also already mentioned pmc is there may
be the factor library and that has been
useful for I would even say for general
biasing modelling so it is actually to
start it is a little bit hard there is a
book kim from kim davison poland I guess
probabilistic pies in programming for
hackers that could be a good start if
you are if you are not familiar with
library but it looks like quite numpy
computation except decorators so this
sticker and there are three different
decorators one of them is potential the
stochastic and deterministic so
implementation there is no potential but
maybe I could tell a little bit about
determine singer and stochastic
deterministic means we have parent
variables and we are trying to get the
child variable in the sense that we want
to sample for
parent variables deterministic means if
the if those parent variables are
deterministic then the child variable is
also deterministic pants is that
stochastic even even the parent will
variables are deterministic the child
variable is not necessarily
deterministic but could be a stochastic
variable so in this example I didn't
show the butt what signal we are dealing
with so they are so in in in this case
we want to capture these outliers but
this signal is looks like a linear
signal in this case we want also to a
linear regression on top of this signal
by removing those outliers in this case
we have just slope and intercept models
and then we have an outlier model which
which is a likelihood of what likelihood
likelihood of the outliers we want to
capture this is a Gaussian this is based
on a Gaussian outlier basically what we
are trying to do is we want to get rid
of the observations that have high
separate libraries and then preserve the
ones details some of aligned with the
slope and intercept and then run our
mcmc on top of these models so desired
posterior distributions in the y axis
the first graph shows the slope oh and
this signal is 2x x plus can the slope
is gets Martin maximize around to the
intercept gifts maximized around 10
apart unlike the 50 and median filtering
approaches we could also reason about
the outlier information which is I think
very useful we could get the outlier
probability of
signal separate of the outliers I mean
we could get these characteristics of
the out life from after removing to
after removing from the original signal
as well by using a 15 median filtering
but this is like built-in in Monte Carlo
so this could be another advantage of
using it and in this case it does really
well and so this is box plot of Earth
Thailand original signals as you may
guess that live signal has higher
ratings than the original signals the
mean values are also different but it
doesn't really tell much about the
outliers is we are more interested in
the very soft observations rather than
the means so why this is important
generally statisticians give a high
importance to the confidence in four
intervals and if if you want to estimate
a parameter and it is a huge confidence
interval for like ninety-five percent
then generally that parameter estimation
may not be good in general so removing
outliers and then doing parameter
estimation would be useful for those
cases and as you may expect since we are
able to capture 2x Plus 10 signal we we
could also detect are outliers by MC MC
so we're reading on the pit capture
style outliers the so I'm to tell a
little bit about which so I I don't want
to say you know bout three methods are
working and you know you should be happy
generally this signal the real datasets
are quite different quite hard in here
we could play the gut I guess
is we know the parameters what we want
to estimate in the first place but
biasing approach has I think a lot of
advantages over the FFT and median
filtering approach so if tip generally
if price are not known but we have a lot
of knowledge around models how how noise
is generated or how at least we could
reason about what does outliers look
like and if our models captured that
type of information quite well I think
even if the priors are not known that
doesn't really matter at the end of the
day the second if the priors are not
generally you can't really use the price
in the frequentist approaches but you
could just easily incorporate into the
biasing models as prior information also
it is probabilistic you could kind of
reason about probabilities of the of the
so it doesn't produce just one number
you could say you know it could be two
with this probability it could be ten
the intercept could be done with this
probability i think it is also another
useful thing also if the model that you
are trying to capture are more complex
and you may have some knowledge around
what type of what type of process could
produce outputs you could kind of build
am stacked approaches different models
more complex models in biasing setting
whereas you generally need to cascade
different systems in the frequentist
methods so also it is a couple of
disadvantages so in fft medium
I think we didn't do really anything
beforehand we just look at method and
then run on the signal but embarrassing
setting we need to do a lot of careful
planning what type of priors we are
using what type of models we are trying
to capture so this of the inference
kemah should be designed and should be
known generally frequentist I guess this
is one of the biggest disadvantage of
pairs modeling in general but
computation and i'll also alberta mice
frequencies approaches are just very
simple and also runs faster then for
example monte carlo markov chain and
hopefully we learn a little bit this is
also so there are a lot of discussions
around went to remove outliers and how
to deal with it this is I guess a good
and I thought that if you need to decide
also after you captured outliers if if
it is actually an outlier or it could be
a valuable data point in general also it
may provide a much different information
than what your general signal looks like
hopefully we learnt a little bit about
how teas are trans even if not to drink
water we could just let and two credits
the one of the visualization actual
didn't really work well maybe I could go
over that one of it I think that
explains quite valid so this is our
signals um this is a bunch of cosine
signals this is if you remember e to the
minus J 2 pi k / enter so what we are
trying to do is I'm just get the
correlation with the original signal and
to get the Fourier coefficients so at
the end of today we have a bunch of
Fourier coefficients which corresponds
to discrete Fourier transform and this
is original signal looks like in our
case the frequency component is a bunch
of noise components and also our
original signals yeah and
yep so the source of the presentation is
also in my github repo the
visualizations are from taken from the
10 cus vivid tumblr and the first image
is from XKCD and I guess the added
concludes my presentation thanks I guess
if you have some time
so so your first example how do you pick
the threshold even this is in general so
in fft also there are two parameters
that needs to be somehow defined i think
that is quite application dependent
because at the end of today it really
depends on how much you want to capture
right like if you want to if you want to
really be flexible and then get the
quite outliers like quite distant ones
then you could put high threshold but if
you want to be conservative and if you
have a like a predefined range for your
signals then you could maybe lower the
threshold and then and then do it that
way generally like a global threshold
may not work in general the sliding
window approach I guess remedies that
disadvantage of that problem because if
you are aware like a time varying signal
even if it's moot when you put a global
threshold at some point the signal kind
of goes over that threshold and when you
just remove it you may also lose the
original signal but for the like local
threshold I guess it depends on how much
you want to really preserve how much you
want to capture
so you mentioned using cascading FFT to
detect outliers for more complex signals
how do you compare that with the
Bayesian approach of the results compare
so I'm like we have seasonal data I
think periodic signals in general FFT is
way to go because it is easy it is kind
of you could easily get easily get the
frequency components quite well like
maybe you could kind of get quite easily
the frequency compounds of the signal
and if you have a really black periodic
signals then the frequency components
would be quite high and it would be
rather easy to just you know get rid of
whatever below threshold but I think if
you have the computation power and also
if you know the models that you want to
capture in in this case linear and if
you have like a similar to sinusoids and
if your if your model kind of could
imitate that process in in some way then
I think in general I'd prefer I'm cnc
because it is probabilistic in fft you
don't get really a lot at the end of the
day in mcmc you kind of get like also
the distribute and characteristics of
the distribution the outlier information
but I think if you have a like very
regular periodic signal I think yeah you
may want to go with effort so you
partially replied already but for non
periodic signals FFTs rule of right um
yeah if so if you if you don't have a
like a quite periodic signal but you
know if the signal where i slowly like
it
jumpy signal right so generally general
the natural signals are like this log
low-pass like low-frequency signals so
what you could do is just get a portion
of the signal like a low frequency range
and then remove all other parts this is
actually called low-pass filtering what
what averaging windows are actually
doing but if you if you have what a like
a slow frequency component in the signal
and also high frequency so some may some
may imagine that we have a signal over
some range which very slowly and then it
gets quickly right then yeah it may not
be very easy but in a mess mcmc also you
need to design the model in that way so
i look at the signal if the signals
range is somehow limited or regular if i
want to capture the low frequency i
would call it FFT but if i could design
the model to keep capture the signal
itself I would go with MCM say I guess
oh I'll do you want so can you talk a
little bit about the tools are currently
available inside our secular that are
you know you should a lot of code how
you implement these things from scratch
or they're just any canned libraries
single processing which ones are the
best in Python that you found so in
signal processing I generally Saipan
numpy now pay is a 50 building and i'll
say a bunch of signal processing tools
that are available i generally depend on
those scikit-learn doesn't really have
anything useful for time series signals
although the other stuff they they they
they get really well in time series
signals even like a hidden Markov model
doesn't exist inside
learn so i guess non-parents type I are
like very good also the neuroimaging
people produce like have a lot of
available tool box sadly i'm not using
enough dose but if you are doing
something like more complex wavelet or
something that is more involved in time
series signals may want to look at those
scikit-learn has an implementation for
outlier detection but it is not time
series signals specific it looks at it
like two dimension or high dimensional
space and then it uses an assembly one
class based approach to detect those
outliers yeah you may want also
considered if you're kind of signal is
not in time series but like image or
text one question from there
we mentioned Monte Carlo Markov chain
how would how do you the arrow just
threw a petition or do you do something
special um so in general PMC provides
out of convergence but that is like one
of the biggest problem that I found in
in experiments whether I should increase
the number of iterations or should i do
something in the model itself so I
generally look at the trace I MC
provides a trace and error functions if
those functions seem not to decrease
over time in the sense that number of
iterations and the end result doesn't
really look anything useful then I
assume something problematic in my
models and if the error somehow gets you
know gets decrease over time but not
necessarily not necessarily fast enough
then I guess you need to look at a
little bit about times internals with
general i find myself why does this you
know decreases fast enough or why does
this decreases very slowly i found
general myself in those situations pmc
generally is high-level library but has
a lot of internal like flags parameters
optional parameters that you could tune
in generally I'm CMC somehow depends on
the parameterization a lot so you may
want to treat those if the address some
of medium level that you could do you
could tune the parameters basically all
right thanks Cerebus concludes this talk
will have breaks right now and then I
guess converge back here for a keynote
so thank you very much thank you